[Music]
[Applause]
well I've been of
changing cuz i'
bu it was so sad Joey VTO joined us and
he said prior to his last game with the
Reds he played this song 15 times just
started crying
Joey V Red's first baseman joining us
now where are you
Joey uh I'm in rovic I think that's how
you pronounce it Iceland right now I
just landed actually a few hours ago so
you woke me up from from my sleep why
are you went a wake up call why I've
never been I've never been and uh I
wanted to make a stop for a few days I
heard it's beautiful okay what do you
think so far have you seen anything cold
what it's it's it is I Woke Up This
excuse me I landed this morning was
Pitch Black outside so I have no idea
what it is but um I can't wait to
explore I mean I love to I love to
travel okay just be careful when you
when you take a car around Iceland um
just make sure that you're aware of
black ice okay we'll do yes have you
been uh my family went twice and uh but
they loved it loved it good but they did
uh they hit a some black ice and you
know started spinning so oh my yeah so
just just be careful I don't know what
the temperatures are but uh just be just
be aware of that uh have you been
recognized in uh
rovic no I haven't but I'll I'll be sure
to wear my my uniform out about when I
go that would be funny if you just show
up at the bar with your full uniform on
have some black you know you put the
black under your eye that'd be good good
hi
everyone oh it's yeah I I'd wear Red's
uniform but um you know if it's an
astute fan they someone would be like
you don't even work for them right now
so how can you wear that
uniform okay now so you're not GNA watch
the baseball playoffs do you even care I
I knew I was going to speak to you this
morning so on the flight down I watched
highlights from every game so I had
something to talk about because I
thought nobody wants to keep hearing me
you know uh ask Taylor out you know
through a third party or talk about you
know retirement stuff I think that I
speak baseball and I was hoping to do
some baseball you know chatting with you
so I'd love to I'd love to be I'd love
to do that with you okay did you get any
feedback first of all with shooting your
shot with Taylor Swift it's been a
week yeah I had I had uh a few people
basically laugh at me so I I I got no
feedback whatsoever no okay what about
to you playing the song Landslide 15
times in a row in Weeping before your
last game did you get any sympathy any
women reach out to you no I I felt like
that was personal I don't know why I
shared that with you to be honest I was
pretty embarrassed afterwards it was one
of those moments I was like why why' you
share that why did you have to share
that you didn't have to share that what
are you doing especially you know I the
the thing I noticed the most the
feedback I got the most was me saying
I'm coming back and playing and uh I
heard a lot about that through texts and
through you know media and stuff like
that so uh thank you for giving me an
opportunity to share that publicly I
didn't realize you your platform touched
a few I you know so yeah
uh I have a big
platform I know now I know now I thought
this was like a m mom Mom Pop operation
you know did you flee to Iceland to get
away from you know the questions about
Taylor Swift or your future in baseball
and being staying in Cincinnati is that
what you're doing no I no I I I flew
here so I could throw my uniform on and
test to see whether or not the Iceland
Market is for me you know whether or not
there's there's a draw here so uh not so
much not so much uh the social scene is
very good in rovic just let I've heard
that I heard the city's right and the
people look great excuse me the people
seem great friendly I sat next to a
woman on the plane last night and she
was telling me all about uh what to go
see and and so friendly so friendly so I
look forward to it all right some
baseball here uh let me start with um
celebrating in the locker room with the
goggles fritzy has a problem when you
know just Justin Verlander and the
asteroids he said they're soft because
yes are they soft if you wear wear
goggles during the celebration in the
locker room it it depends on the team I
know when I was when I first came came
up newly inducted Scott Hall of Famer
Scott Rolland said listen buddy if I
catch you wearing those goggles during
the celebration we're goingon to have an
issue sort of thing but I mean now it's
part of you know playoff celebration it
seems to me everybody's wearing goggles
so fritzy might be right he may be old
he sounds like fritzy's old school oh
yeah very yeah very very old school of
course old school what kind of question
I mean how could I how could I miss that
but what one of the danet one of the
danet is that after planets is that
danet planets like one of your guys is
Mars one's you know Urus who who is
Uranus you know that would be Todd ah
that that would that would be Todd no
Reggie Miller named them the
danet and like so I he just called him
the danet one day and then people would
say don't you know that that would mean
they're women and I go I give that much
what does it matter what does it matter
it's one of the danet yeah I just's got
a real personality on him I met him I
met him a good bit good bit ago yeah
good guy good guy uh did you care about
the Astros when they were
cheating you know I was quoted saying
I'd be surprised if they were the only
one yeah um I I of of course you're
aware of it I don't know the depths to
which they were were doing that um but I
will say the the second that uh Manfred
Rob Manfred laid down the the the
punishment I moved on completely I'm a
I'm a Believer once once you've served
time once you've served a a punishment
it's over same with the players
everybody involved that's my take but
they didn't serve any time the only
people got punished were the manager in
the GM that's what I think that's the
problem with the Astros if they served
their time they got suspended whatever
it might be then I think people would
move on from it but it feels are you
saying specifically the players yes well
how do you know who's who how do you
know who benefited who didn't are you
saying the entire Team all all roster
players throughout the entire season
even if it exceeds 40 well some players
cooperated players players had immunity
so therefore they told the commissioner
whatever you know you ask me a question
I'll give you an answer there's no
repercussions there so we know that
there was cheating because people paid a
price
my point is they keep winning and I keep
saying well why did you cheat in the
first place if you guys were this good
did were you ever aware of the Astros
cheating during a game no and I don't I
I don't know their players very well we
rarely play them in inter league yeah we
obviously don't play them during the
regular season we don't we weren't a
strong team during that window so I he
didn't match up in the playoffs so it
was almost like you know from another
continent and then when you hear all the
reports and you see the commentary
that's when you perk yours up and you
ask the question oh what's going on here
you know is this is this ubiquitous you
know among all the winning teams um but
as far as the players I think I I don't
know the investigation I know so little
about this subject other than they were
they were dinged and a lot of people in
the industry thought that yes they were
they were punished
appropriately talking to Joey vad are
you still listed as the Red's first I
mean I don't how to introduce you you
just I don't know how I think I I don't
know I think my contracts uh finished up
November one I think so I'm still the
Red's uh first baseman uh or a first
base option but season's done so would
you check the Red's official roster as
of this morning yeah I got that that
would hurt that would hurt if what is it
what what do you want to hear Joey I
want to hear the truth okay and no I
still can't hand I'm on the Red's
website and MLB's website you're still
listed
asite how about that yeah 62220 yeah are
you 6 pulling that up no 230 you know co
co so my dog died at the very beginning
of Co and I used to go for multiple
walks a day and for like the last year
or two I've put on maybe five seven
pounds and I realized now it's because I
didn't I'm not walking my dog anymore
once twice a day I'd walk for 75 minutes
or so and I think over the years that I
was 222 to 227 and now I'm like 228 to
232 so I gotta I my goal is to tighten
up get back down to close to 225 plus if
you want to meet a woman having a puppy
come on I know it worked it used to work
it
worked uh explain to me the
Dodgers how does that happen yes well I
think the five game series is tough and
before we go I'd love to chat about the
RCA Harper uh exchange but I think the
five game series is tough and I think
there's a reason why people get excited
real baseball I'm not saying real
Baseball fans but there's so much
Randomness during the Major League
playoffs especially with the shorter
series The three- game series the five
game series so you know next thing you
know they're down two nothing and they
put up four homers in one inning and
it's like that's the sort of feeling I
remember in 2012 and I don't mean to go
so far back but we were playing the San
Francisco Giants we were up two
games two games after you know beating
them in San Francisco coming back to
Cincinnati and they came back and tied
it 2-2 and in the second third fourth in
Buster posie had a Grand Slam in game
five and it just felt like we're about
to you know that feeling of like how do
you come back from this and I think that
may have been the sensation you know for
straight home runs how do we come back
from this sort of thing in such a short
series I'm I'm sensing that's probably
what happen I don't know how much you
can control in the
playoffs the Bryce Harper situation so
he gets doubled up the night before and
then all of a sudden hits a couple of
home runs and then stares down one of
the players who kind of made fun of him
a little bit in the in the locker room
after the game no no not kind of and and
this is what I think baseball needs more
of I think we need these exchanges first
of all Bryce is one of the more iconic
players in our sport obviously one of
the better players in our sport best
players in our sport two-time Most
Valuable Player Orlando arcia I if I'm
not mistaken started the All-Star Game
this year so he's a successful player in
his own right I think these exchanges
between teams uh between Stars between
players I think will really and tell
that story tell that story um and that
way we get to have those moments and you
know the photo of Harper looking back at
Aria I mean how good is is that for for
a baseball fan the big moments you could
sense you could sense the anger you know
I I think and I'm not going to Min here
but I think the average baseball fan
wants to hear the the anger the emotion
the hatred the spite you know I
guarantee when Aria and Harper step away
from the field and the series is done
they dap each other up handshake each
other and come on it's just competition
but in competition give us that context
out a boy Harper way to you know he's
kind of making fun of him way to run the
bases he hears it and then all of a
sudden he's like all right you want to
talk about me let me show you what I can
do with this bat let me let me you know
put a dagger in this game sort of thing
so Phillies are up two to one I think
just out of just out of Spike that was a
spite win almost what's that sound be
great serious they'll play five I bet
you they play five what's that sound
like when you're at first base in
somebody
homers sharp like like sharp sounding
it's it's a distinct sound if you put me
behind The Dugout where I can't see the
game and I faced away from the game and
I just listen to the game I could tell
you that's a flare foul ball that's a
popup in the infield and I'd be pretty
darn close and I could tell I could tell
for sure I I could tell the rockets for
sure it's hard to tell the Homer because
the the hard hit balls and the Homer
sound the same but the distinct down and
then you feel the the buildup of the
crowd the and then the the the reaction
afterwards it's all one sound but there
are certain players who have a different
sound when they hit the base I remember
hearing Jo
Peterson and the ball left his Bat and I
went that sounds different are are there
guy like is there a sound from a
player's bat that like he's different
than anybody else yeah I I I hit with
Peak a hit with Josh Hamilton after he
came off of the r the red Signum before
them even a minor league extin just that
sound we were hitting in Sarasota
Florida with these dud balls they were
soaked in beaten up and that sound and
there's only a few players that have
that sound it's distinct you know when a
when a you know now y Don Alvarez when a
Bryce Harper when the when the judges
hit the ball it's a it's a different
sound and then you can feel the heat off
the off the barrel you're watching for
that ball because it's scary so sound
off the bat the sound of the ball
traveling through the air you know the
more you play and the more you're close
to action yes there are some distinct
sounds I think I can honestly say you're
the best baseball analyst in Iceland
right now yeah wow how about
that thank you thank you danet I appreci
yes Jupiter Saturn thank you guys the
planets what is your plan for the rest
of the day in
Iceland get up get out I I I hear you
know I I'm an older I'm an older guy and
I got to get in those thermal pools you
know I got to soak the aching bones so
uh I'll probably get up and get out and
and it's not a good hiking day but I'd
love to go for a walk here soon okay be
careful definitely watch out for black
ice yeah how long are you there
for um a few days
this too much information Dan let's
let's keep you know
you let's not tell people where my
cordinates are okay you know if I tell
if I say five six days all of a sudden
it's GNA be a crowd of Joey botle fans
looking for me in my uniform
you're by the way I got a question for
you before before It Go is is is Pluto a
planet is Pluto a danet uh
no I yeah intern Pluto is an
intern an intern if you play next year
you have to promise this audience that
Landslide will be your walk up
song I want landslide to be the walkout
song I use on the last day the
season no then you'll be crying you'll
be at the pl why why would I cry opening
day you're trying so I have to normalize
I have to build up a callus to the song
yeah wait you cry on opening day
if I walked out to Fleetwood Max
Landslide yes okay I just I like that
I'm the best analyst in Iceland by the
way thank
you good luck with that at the bar
tonight thank you it'll work well it
could you know I am the big I am the
best ice uh analyst in Iceland baseball
you know yeah
yeah here we go we say goodbye to Joey
V he may have played his last game
[Music]
God if John Smoltz goes to Iceland Joey
VTO gets kicked down a notch as far as
baseball analy
damn
man once
again hey it hits me it hits me hard too
Joey he cries after every appearance
here on The Dan Patrick
Show women love that he's
vulnerable even more an ice they love
that that's Joey vono former MVP he
actually won a gold glove you know what
I should ask him for his Gold Glove he's
not using that thing